Let's see if we can develop some
intuition as to why the
equilibrium constant equation
looks the way it does.
Just as review, this is it:
equilibrium constant.
It would be the concentration
of our molecule Y raised to
its coefficient power or, if
we're thinking in moles,
raised to the number of moles.
If we think of these as kind
of the mole ratios, or the
molar ratios-- or we could
just view them as the
molecular ratios, either way--
times the concentration of our
molecule Z.
Now, we're not doing
some calculus here.
d is just the number of moles we
need of Z for every c moles
of Y, b moles of X,
and a moles of V.
So it's Z to the d power divided
by the concentration
of V to the a power and
X to the b power.
So it's a nice, little, clean
equation, but why does
it look this way?
And I actually made a video
earlier today where I started
exploring this with
natural logs.
And I think I got someplace,
but that one
started to break down.
And I think I've come up with a
much simpler reason why this
looks this way.
So I've deleted that video, and
I think I've come up with
a much more intuitive one that
explains more of why this
works and actually some of the
other things we're going to
learn about the equilibrium
constants in future videos.
So what makes a reaction
happen?
Or what does equilibrium mean?
It means the rate at which the
forward reaction is happening.
So that means that the rate of
this happening, of V plus X
turning into Y plus Z--
I can't forget the
coefficients-- is going to be
equal to the reverse reaction,
is equal to the rate of
the reverse reaction.
So our c moles of Y plus d moles
of Z turning and going
the other way, turning
into the V and the X
with certain ratios.
It doesn't mean necessarily that
the concentrations are
the same, because we could
have one where we end up
heavily favoring the
forward reaction.
Where we end up with much higher
concentrations of Y and
Z, or we might heavily favor the
backwards reactions where
we have more V and X.
But when we're in equilibrium,
we're saying that our
concentrations have reached a
stability point, which implies
that the rate of going in this
direction is equal to the rate
going into that direction.
So let's just think a little
bit about what drives these
rates, what drives these
rates of reactions.
In order for this forward
reaction to happen that I drew
in purple, what needs
to happen?
We have to have a molecules
of V roughly.
And let's say in any volume of
space, we have to have some V
molecules, and preferably a
V molecules, being in the
vicinity of b X molecules.
So there's got to be b of these
X molecules, and they
have to be in the right
configuration and in the right
place and kind of close
enough in order for
the reaction to happen.
So the reaction is really going
to be driven by, if you
think about it, the probability
of finding a V
molecules and b molecules all
within close enough confines
that they can actually react.
So you could say that the rate
is going to be driven by--
maybe it's going to
be proportional.
Let's say it's just equal to--
let's say some constant that
takes into account things like
temperature and how the
molecules are actually
configured.
Because it's not dependent
just on them being there.
You have to have worry about
their kinetic energies.
You have to worry about their
shape, because some shapes are
going to be more conducive
to reaction than others.
So let's just let that be taken
into account with a K.
And we're talking about the
forward reaction, right?
So in order for the forward
reaction to happen, let's call
that K plus for the
forward reaction.
We have to have a molecules of
V there and b molecules of X.
So what's the probability of
having a molecules of X?
Or what's a rough approximation
of the
probability?
Well, the concentration.
Let's think about
this a second.
When we write the concentration
of the molecule
V, which I think when I did this
was the blue one right
here, what is that given in?
That is given in moles
per liter.
Moles is just a number, so this
tells us, look, in any
given volume, roughly how
many of the molecules do
you expect to find?
That's what concentration is.
So if I wanted to figure out the
probability of finding a
of these molecules, because
that's how many I need, I need
to multiply this by
itself a times,
because I need a of them.
The probability of having just
one molecule in just some
small fraction, you would just
use the concentration once.
But you're going to use it a
times, because you want a of
those molecules there, right?
You could look at it like what's
the probability of
having five heads?
Well you would multiply
the probability of
one head five times.
So the forward reaction
probability is going to be the
concentration of V to the a
power, and, of course, that's
not enough to have the
reaction happen.
You also need to have b of
the X molecules there.
So you have the concentration
of X to the b power.
And I want to make sure
you understand this.
My claim is that this is
approximation-- or actually
it's a pretty good way of
calculating-- the probability.
So let me write it this way.
The rate is equal to some
constant that takes into
account the temperature and the
molecular configurations
times the probability of having
a V molecules and b X
molecules in a sufficiently
small area
all at the same time.
And the best way to approximate
that is with their
concentration.
Obviously, the higher the
concentration, the higher the
moles per liter, the more likely
you're going to find
that many of molecules in kind
of that little small space
that you care about, and
the temperature and the
configuration are going
to matter more.
But if you use the concentration
as the
probability of a-- let
me switch colors.
If the probability of having a V
molecule in some volume-- if
we assume that the solution
is homogeneous, that the V
molecules are roughly evenly
distributed, it's going to
be-- this isn't even
an approximation.
It's going to be the
concentration of the V
molecules times the volume under
which we care about.
If we want the probability of
a, where a is a number, it
could be five V molecules, a V's
in some volume, it's the
probability of finding
this a times.
So it's going to be equal to--
and this is just from the
probability concepts that
we learned in the whole
probability playlist.
So if you want to have five
heads in a row, it's 1/2 to
the fifth power.
If you want to have V molecules
there, five of them
at the same time in some volume,
or a of them, it's
going to be V to the a power
times the volume.
If you also care about the
probability so you want all of
that, so a V's and b X's in some
volume, then you're going
to have to multiply all
of them together.
So it's going to be equal to the
concentration of V to the
a power times the concentration
of X to the b
power times the volume.
So the probability of finding
the right number of V
particles and X particles in the
right place in some volume
is going to be proportional
to exactly this.
And we're saying that the
reaction rate, the forward
reaction rate, is also
proportional to this thing.
So that's where we get the
forward reaction rate.
So the rate forward is equal to
the concentration of our V
molecules to the a power times
the concentration of our X
molecules to the b power.
Now, if we want to find the
reverse rate, so this is the
rate forward.
If we want to find the rate of
the reverse reaction, let's
say that that's equal to some
other constant-- let's call
that K-minus-- the same
exact logic holds.
We're just going in this
direction now.
If we look at our original
one, we're
going in that direction.
So for this reaction, we
do the same thing.
We literally just do different
letters, so the reverse
reaction is just going to be
the concentration of the Y
molecule to the c power, because
we need c of them
there roughly at the same time,
times the concentration
of the Z molecule
to the d power.
Now, just at the beginning of
the video, we said that
equilibrium is when these
rates equal each other.
I wrote it down right here.
So if the reverse rate is equal
to some constant times
this, and the forward rate is
equal to some constant times
that, then we reach equilibrium
when these two are
equal to each other.
Let me clear up some
space here.
Let me clear this up, too.
So when are they going to
be equal to each other?
When the forward rate-- the
forward rate is this.
That's our forward constant,
which took into account a
whole bunch of temperature and
molecular structure and all of
that-- times the concentration
of our V
molecule to the a power.
You can kind of view that as
what's the probability of
finding in a certain volume--
and that certain volume can be
factored into that K factor
as well-- but what's the
probability of finding
V things, a V
molecules in some volume.
And it's the concentration
of V to the a power times
concentration of X to the V
power-- that's the forward
reaction-- and that has to equal
the reverse reactions.
So K-minus times the
concentration of Y to the c
power times the concentration
of Z to the d power.
Now, if we divide both sides
by-- let me erase more space.
Nope, not with that.
All right.
So let's divide both sides by
K-minus and both sides by
this, so you get K-plus over
K-minus is equal to that, is
equal to Y to the c
times Z to the d.
All of that over that-- V to the
a times the concentration
of X to the V.
Let me put this in magenta just
so you know that this was
this K-minus right here.
And then, these are just two
arbitrary constants, so we
could just replace them
and call them
the equilibrium constant.
And we're there where
we need to be.
We're at the formula for the
equilibrium constant.
Now, I know this was really hand
wavy, but I want you to
at least get the sense that this
doesn't come from out of
the blue, and there is-- at
least I think there is--
there's an intuition here.
These are really calculating the
probabilities of finding--
this is the forward reaction
rate probabilities
proportional to this.
Because the more V concentration
you have, the
more likely you're
able to find it.
Although if you need more of
those particles around, you're
going to have to multiply that
concentration by each other,
because the probability's
going to get lower.
Because you need more of them
together in order for the
reaction to happen.
Same thing for everything
there.
But all this is derived from is
that the forward reaction
should be equal to
some constant
times the reverse reaction.
Or actually, their rates should
be equal, but then when
you actually calculate the
probability, you'll have a
constant in there.
Anyway, hopefully, I didn't
confuse you, but I just wanted
to give you that this isn't
just some random equation.
It really does, I think, come
from the reality that the
higher the concentration you
have, the more the probability
you have of the actual
molecules
bumping into each other.